ah snake oil the phrase is often used to
characterize grifters and con artists
but where did the same come from well
the story starts in the 1800s Chinese
immigrants working on the first
transcontinental railroad rub snake oil
on their skin to treat joint pain
Westerners eventually caught on and
marveled at its apparent healing powers
while some admired it others saw
opportunity in comes Clark rattlesnake
king Stanley he was a self-proclaimed
cowboy and so-called expert in
traditional Native American medicine
we're going to make a quick buck he
teamed up with a boston druggist and
began marketing clark Stanley's snake
oil in a miracle medicine promised to
heal your rheumatism neuralgia sciatica
blame back lembaga toothache sore throat
animal bites Gungan disease alright that
last one isn't real but who cares the
sucker would fix anything that L did
Clark took his product on the road
visiting fairs and put on elaborate
spectacles in front of a hungry crowd
during one show he squeezed the snake to
death and bottled up its residue while
some were mesmerised others were
skeptical after seeing the injustice is
made to Public Health famous muckraker
Samuel Hopkins Adams investigated the
fraudulent patent medicine industry
and wrote the watershed expose the great
American fraud this led to the federal
government seizing a shipment of the
snake oil and analyzing it they found
out that it was made mostly just mineral
oil the quack medicine industry came to
an end when the Pure Food and Drug Act
was passed the feds slapped Clark with a
$20 fine and he promptly closed up shop
so samuel exposed the frauds Clark
Stanley had the last laugh
you
[Music]